[Music]
what is up everybody
good morning and welcome to kin spa live
how's it go hi Richie we're joining you
guys today and we're back at it again
with some more apex legends
oh yeah yesterday we were pretty hype
that was the kickoff to season four yeah
I actually didn't because we had max
holding it down for us on the stream so
today I'm trying him out got Richie in
here yeah game chance you see our lobby
let's do it I mean the game scene there
we go so yeah I'm gonna be playing
revving in but hey he has specials yes
that's my favorite skin of his I mean
his goat so it's pretty perfect it's
pretty fitting so he will be carrying
[Music]
his legendary that's cool I want that
one but that one is cool really gotta
have a variant though but I want that
one he's so cool I love this skin he's
so moody I love I love his character
overall regular ones right we'll
probably get first and then the you know
some little loot boxes things yes oh my
goodness but as soon as I get enough
crafting materials I am getting that
skin right there looks so sick so cool
anywho hope you guys have been pulling
some apex legends now that season four
have started because it's pretty cool
yeah we added some new life into the
game I'm back yeah let's do this
readying up ready hopefully hey is also
ready if not it takes two will go with
Adam I think doesn't it were you wet no
he'll be here in a second I mean we did
start the stream like five minutes early
very very okay which is luck y'all yeah
seriously I need all the luck I can get
but honestly this character looks super
cool oh nice I even put both friendly
and hostile legends can activate a death
totem which I found out yesterday I
killed the whole squad and I saw someone
else's totem there and I was like let me
just see Aniki it works that's big even
though if you die you go back to that
always got that he's even got that cool
Pathfinder skin I love that I'm gonna be
my main optic robust why yeah
thank you - banana yes banana the
minions
there was that vine of that voice actor
pretending to be the guy who does the
means he's like by night
Rodimus crying back in the jab apex high
revenue is an awesome character best
added character so far om the jumpmaster
to her first game was rather than ever
let's frickin do this where are we going
hmm I think I would like to go there
let's drop deport oh you have my
approval a shin nation you know what's
up already
tastes like Eric you're killing buzz bro
wait did anybody drop your because I
didn't hear anybody
I saw one near me oh this is interesting
I'm hearing your gunfire in my
headphones oh yeah you have to plug your
headphones into your controller okay oh
I got charged I got hit with the charged
rifle that guy's still up there okay
with the purple deal
okay there's definitely a knocking down
on the ground level
oh no there can only be one I need a
shield before okay take all right I'm on
my way I'm kind of far but I'm coming
come back you knock down one did Eric
knock down another does that might be
their third revenant no I'm coming
who you are
and they realize somebody wet
I see him though 1v1 with octane
their octane down me but he's really low
on health he's punching me on my shield
I'm gonna plug into actually yeah I saw
three streams we had third party at the
last second well you know warm up that's
right what's going on sorry it's hard
when we're both like playing the game oh
yeah but we got you how much has this
game change haven't played in about
seven months well Eli you're in for a
treat because over the last seven months
I think there was what like three new
characters now the time to come back ton
of balance there's new weapons it's all
kinds of crazy all right take two
honestly I wasn't a bad start
considering that we dropped into a spicy
one
I wanted that r3l one but I knew someone
was running towards me so I only had an
R 33 I'm sorry r 99 but uh the guy yeah
they're mine just just a rough start for
me I didn't have a shield - mm-hmm but
excuses excuses excuses that's all I
gotta say for me I
get good yeah hey a leg warm-up game
there he is in the chat soggy
I knew it was gonna be spicy I just
needed something that like it gets the
blood pumping right that did it before
we
all right they need to be a lifeline
I've had good luck with like I'm gonna
ditch the robos oh yeah there's a whole
new map yes the map yeah
there's a lot that has happened in seven
months if you haven't seen it we have a
one-year retrospect on a pentru days hex
legends live on our Channel right now
produced by Max and Jordan so check it
out if you feel like you want to catch
up on what you've missed and if you want
to jump back in we also got a revenant
guy coming from those guys cities I mean
those trailers were pretty hype and then
like watching that video that Jordan max
made like just pushed me over the edge
it kind of was I just jump back into
apex I hadn't played for a while not
seven months but lips yeah
there's a bunch eating area most
how's it looking
anybody tailing us
they're people one squad to our left but
they're gonna land earlier than we are
attachments for a gun but no gun feeling
okay more than one spotty or anything
[Music]
well he got me I think there's a
are like 50 people here Eric shrine is
back that was that was we were supposed
to we're trying to drop a little colder
oh oh you like this thanks for the
answer I'll have to get back into it
yes please do it's free-to-play you know
how it goes
yeah that was actually the main reason
why I downloaded this to begin with I
was like oh we're free to play FPS games
even though I wasn't a big fan of battle
royale it's just cuz I like respawning I
don't know about you but we're in the
same boat like I wasn't a big fan of
Battle Royale in general you know when
it came to Cod but I downloaded I was
like I got nothing to lose and then I
thought you know what no I'm gonna pick
like this will change our yes
coolest moodiest intro it's a Crouch
walk more I keep forgetting that that's
one of the time yeah we got a got a
channel in our fun back stop
I must become death Jam yes basically
what up hey Ryan how's it going happy
Wednesday
thanks for tuning in Bob Jones back in
the chat good to see alright I'm John
master Laura can I please land somewhere
in a decent my orange easels are really
bad so me being junk master isn't
necessarily lets not fly through that
terrifying beam
I have one
like your focus it's all good
I think
well that wasn't all around that oh yeah
he's got straps
this trap got popped okay I can only
assume
I only have already called
I only have a grenade there is no other
interest in this game for the gamers so
thinking of installing this again the
new character looks insane it's he's
super cool I mean I'm not showing him
off very well but his ability is really
good like it can silence people we do
forgot that these windows are fake so I
tried to like bounce it off the window
look and I shot it outside of the room
oh you did yeah shoot I body myself okay
but it's all good recovery I don't know
where it sounded like Eric took care of
it okay there's like three death boxes
in here oh nice yeah see this is why we
got Taeyeon's he yeah oh to carry yeah I
still have no drop in the lava get some
hot combat going yeah seriously no bro
we know what happens the lava though I
think it only does like your true damage
so if you guys have a full shield and
you're in the lava we're gonna have a
little bit of a gunfight in there yeah
some of the areas though like if you
were to have fallen to your desk you
like get a random jet pack and it pushes
you back up do that really yeah you know
I don't know this much do you map so
much I thought yesterday I was
that's great yeah
gameboy says I'm a beast at titanfall I
remember trying Titan fella and I don't
really like it so oh wait guns for me
and so I I never really got any time
ball to because of that but when I
played I wanted to get into x bar it is
a reverse order for me because I didn't
play does a little bit of the history
guys if there's a first game I like to
play first so I tried I wanted to play
titanfall one before I played anything
but it was only an xbox exclusive and
he's a triple take in a while probably
my favorite sniper quote unquote sniper
area we're in the ring this is good news
if you see like a basic I still need a
shield I got nothing
Junior it says [ __ ] hands mode are you
still warming up let's just consider
every match I play warm-up for me it's
both I'm always just warming up actually
I've been pretty blessed with that for
some reason like I've been a lifelong
gamer that my hands don't get sweaty
that's pretty blessed I definitely I'm
just a sweaty piece I sweat yeah my
forehead everything else get sweaty but
my hands I'm like what is this joke of a
deodorant yeah
it just smells nice but doesn't work
that's a shame
like everyone sweats bro wait what do
what can I get rid of here oh yeah the
trip will take doesn't take those
bullets any more interesting and
honestly I think it's cool because
sometimes I would pick up like 100 heavy
bullets and I'm like I really don't need
100 yeah 100 sniper bullets right now
yeah Oh bless you Erik you finally think
they're shield for now oh my bad I
totally ran in front of like three
shields I wish I can like super thank
people like so much Hemi max man they
just run me dry I can't see like
everything's gone they need it though
they tried the new sniper The Sentinel
yes I you think yesterday actually and I
managed to get a headshot on someone and
it did 124 damage I was like wall that's
dope that's a lot
oh yeah I remember that yesterday's game
gzj shut the door in my face you okay
I'm always closing doors to make it look
like no one has been here then take them
out have a care package you got a self
resurrect so we must protect say at all
cost
yes okay
today's going in I'm trying to go to
he's so fast how is he getting any so
fast he's well he's got no gun run life
where you run faster without a gun when
I watch max play I'm like you are like
it's so fast
okay he's singing singing I'm following
you it's like you guys seriously there's
a thousand me too I cut across the field
I see you on the roof I wish we could
speak with Eric okay I'm ready to engage
we're all kinda like
I broke a sculpture well I did it broke
his BlueShield sorry I did not know that
run from me
he's definitely on the water
okay try to get up there and see if yeah
I'm trying to make my way over there but
I don't want to like make it he only has
a blue shield and he's alone I'm sure I
got somebody guys Oh as soon as I said
that he said I can't drop with some
stranger oh no my looting is so slow and
I don't like that I feel like a sitting
duck yeah we out here quack quack quack
quack city ducks look old helmet dibs
hey that's even better with you that is
the helmet the faster I don't think I
need
oh my robotics course purple shield and
a sniper stock so many grenades if Eric
doesn't want it I'm gonna take it okay
I'll find some on the way Eric is out of
here we need it he's playing eric is
playing apex legends - he's so far gone
does revenant eat he eats your soul he
does he's dead he's a former skin bag um
I mean yeah he's a robot so I don't
think he needs to eat but he definitely
be devouring life oh no wonder the ring
is coming you guys are a hug in the ring
because we're we're gatekeeping I'm
gonna check out this way there's Jack's
why
alright let's see six squads left I need
to heal I forgot I'm used to playing his
octane where he heals himself little by
little
this ain't the case oh I think I have a
what some to call it yeah
ultimate accelerant yeah my Crouch walk
speed is soo good I'm watching you level
tree eric is our brave leader I know
although I'm scoping and I don't see
anything in the distance I see people
been activity through here yeah now Eric
is just you know he's our leader we have
to follow him yep trust Eric there is no
abandonment only leadership you do as
soon as I plugged into my ps4 controller
you also have a dashboard settings that
the volume might be lowered a bit Oh
like within the PlayStation maybe yeah
yeah I just didn't want to interrupt the
game
well someone's dropping us Oh take that
balloon okay I'm gonna follow yeah we uh
[Music]
I was like all right guys let's
strategize and I look over and taste
what's been in care packages lately yeah
it does make me miss it though I don't
[Music]
nice mating the place I was the clan
alright you got it
go here music you did you take them out
dang we didn't get the pick of that
devotion that's right I mean I didn't
want it did you we made it out that's
the important so far away from you guys
Oh
fell down the hill Erickson otherwise is
bent on sweaty up in here yeah Eric is
uh I'm gonna have to heal everything
there's two gold boxes that had to go by
you know I don't know Daniel it you know
I'm using my heel Ibaka thank you
yeah they're gonna have to come to us
because the ring is closing your rings
close oh I need that other dropping
another care package I know I don't want
to be out there
because I'm gonna get sniped and all the
breeze coming in though purple helmet
Chad thanks for hanging in there we
can't really look but we love you thanks
for being here hopefully your bros are
getting sweaty yeah hopefully you guys
are just with us in spirit of course
baloney
I'm being I'm definitely being shot at
so I just want to do maybe you can death
totem and just run our asses off over
there to that side I see they're up
there I'm breaking their shields their
heat they're trying to heal someone
just one outlet schedule but the other
one is still running up just be careful
going down this hill using the death
protection to freaking out y'all blow on
sniper ammo I see their shadow where's
he go though this crowd talking is the
movie Sam idea juice engine spotted an
enemy okay
[Music]
falling in the air strike
No
man we got close oh we got we got we
match yeah that was fun sweaty day is up
going off in Chad I should kill that
bloodhound I miss like my whole first
clip-on yo at least he saw the
Bloodhound I mean I got sniped well I
was trying to heal no bueno
we're going again though we have like an
hour this is great I choked it Eric no
we lay you down bro you were the last
man standing I should I shouldn't miss
my shots bro I didn't I did but I ran
out of bullets
triple take it was it was smaller than
normal but I'll keep an eye out for next
time because I don't specifically know
yeah I wish I picked up that devotion so
the Peacekeeper seemed I was like them
Eric it's gonna be great we can't
let's get this win yeah exactly after
that actually went really well did
considering how our matches are going
yesterday like you broke top five also
playing his lifeline helped our chances
shifted the Mojo as I said one of your
BFFs that actually secretly hates you he
says how are we the champion what they
have
we were the champion in the last one
maybe we just rained higher than
everybody else and this is why yeah I
think I've seen that before
Erick words like no one got a first
place but we got the closest so
weirdness so we have some good odds here
we're the best
losers guys you know what I feel
confident about that Oregon we're drunk
yeah you're surfing where the besties
Oh
I'll take that
you probably got everybody heading our
way yeah there's definitely one I might
be damned I fell next to like three and
I'm not Achtung so I can't run let's
save my own life at least you got a gun
I'm running for my life today
okay good r99 all right and a wing man
whoo I'm a little more comfortable y'all
all right let's see if I can get my
sniping on it helped me out last match
you just got to carry enough bullets I
needed that double that last game story
of my life
yeah I setting me out for a nice heavy
weapons well let's see I got all these
bullets blue an alternator forget heavy
I'm going for this oh it's gorgeous box
still it's still there I wanted to get
that and get the yeah you might be able
to run overnight and get one now okay on
the way I got a shield fell apart no I'm
gonna go post one was that marked are
back from yesterday I wanna guess like
fire longbow clean out or any white day
seen enemy I'm scared that would be no
bueno I'm being targeted
[Music]
we do in chat we need your goodbye
[Music]
Oh Oh I'm now hearing shooting okay
Eric's pinging I'm gonna go check it out
very good though you guys like the new
sniper class shift I do actually cuz
then it's less likely that I'm gonna
have a ton of useless ammo for my sniper
cuz you don't need a hundred bullets of
sniper ammo well I couldn't use that
last round I'm going for it dibs Reno oh
good we all we're all good he's taking
the balloon so thank you swear I go
fight a good thing that lifeline didn't
see me standing there and she had that
gold shield on dang that was a sweet cop
he vanished oh he went to the other side
okay excellent oh we're in the ring so
that's good news yeah carga bot oh don't
you worry
like I can email when you're just using
the balloons to get around I will be on
the lookout there you have one okay cool
that's good news I used to having crappy
it exactly they're just looking after me
I know I needed to charge myself
actually
I missed a turbocharger it's you I was
like I love know like urge to use the
havoc at all anymore and that was with
my favorite guns before none really
Oh Eric scene people and I'm just trying
to drop my care package part of me
thinks I should definitely get that
you're using the creep
oh nice that's all you taking great
the lifeline
you're a lifeline I think that's thank
you chat messenger turbochargers do yeah
it's right here with sake I'm being an
your box is still intact
Oh
I should do an inside
we both got
I was like I can get
Hail Mary play by Eric yeah I wanted to
try and protect you I know you didn't
have anything but they kept they showed
up as soon as I arrived we broke up find
oh cool oh we did we're in that one area
the entire time yeah and like that when
I went to forges box nice give me a
thousand crafting materials anything for
here or that cool skin that you I was
that skin yeah I keep forgetting
revenants Crouch passive is godlike I
need to do that max already like does
that on his own yes he was he was
killing it with that yesterday
it shows you take 5% more damage when
you're in when you're crouching and I
don't know if I can afford to give up
buy a present more damage need every
little bit exactly and I've also been
like playing a lot of octane so not
being able to just like just zip out of
there I know he's usually my main but
we've had better luck when I don't know
Jonathan's okay Gibby
or Eric knows what he's doing with Gibby
oh because he died he tried they try to
suffer we were holding down that area
quite a bit yeah and it was like the hot
spot so I'm impressed with us yeah hey
Jonathan
thanks for joining us yeah see I was
saying the same thing I was like why
didn't I just go inside
[Music]
take the little trip
want Eric a note for us let us know
you're happy let us know you're okay
there he is he's okay folks
and everyone's going to be gone for this
[Music]
checkout so yeah we have to get on the
ground
all right good luck y'all two barrel
stabilizers let's go things are looking
up for you yeah I have a shotgun I have
the Peacekeeper whoo nice it's a good
entry gun and then it's a good like
finishing gun for the match I don't have
a gun I need do you actually don't need
the TT that's where the eBay they
already pay no all right where it's you
guys where to I don't want to go too far
outside the room oh yeah
oh okay one's a nag holds 20 that's
pretty good oh he's jumping Erte has
left the building
oh yeah
sometimes when you play a lot you forget
like what you have incomes in my
equipment I'm like oh wait I already
have one of those or go around before
I'll have a nice backpack and then oh
yeah dude oh no I don't have that
anymore
usually there's better stuff up here
the party was about to go back up to
y'all Wow
cuz I'll have a little white
ah - ooh ooh Eric found another purple
shield for me these fireworks scared the
heck out of me just now I hear popping
off and I thought it was gunshots there
it is
I don't eat it I doubt it I definitely
don't need it really when I'm online
shopping I definitely don't
all right I think this is as good as my
little is gonna get for now so let's
make moves
heck yeah okay Chad how we doing it's
hard it's a little tougher to check a
little both plain but appreciate
appreciate having be in here I mean I
could drop this purple barrel stabilizer
I don't know many good shields over here
now let's go for the gold though
anybody over here in the fiery pits of
hell I'm scared I'm just finding any
cover I can well at least the supply
crates have been untouched yeah I'm
following you then a million barrel
stabilizers SiC he is your barrel stable
I know James like we're the enemies
there's 11 squad where actually I will
because I picked up in our 301 here oh
wow the others doing this that's the
plan you got to be ready to fire
Oh No I gotta get back up oh no I'm so
far dang it
all right today I think he sees them but
he's not engaging and I have a snipper
that's very good should we attack
I just wanna shoot oh I'm watching the
action all right he goes down he got
double team does the party or the
trenches from the east that train is
untied he go on
I just wanted to see if I can get
something good so I second yeah I just
want that something like the dome is
great but then sometimes it's not great
we're definitely from where we were and
the ring is moving this is bad
[Music]
you're being targeted
no just back-to-back battles yeah you
just get stuck in these long battles and
then the next thing you know the ring is
closing no it's always the worst not a
bad game though we were actually we were
we were causing quite a ruckus
Aidan gaming says I subscribed well
thank you yeah appreciate it Gigi's we
got some Jay Wilson says I killed you
good job if that was really you yeah
proud of you bro sick streams night and
then we got action tonight yeah I mean
yet the ring assist oh he just sounds
pretty good otherwise I think I would
definitely would have had him if the
ring wasn't chomping at my health man I
just
I'm normally good about keeping an eye
on the ring but not this time
it was a sweaty battle drop-in if you're
already over the meta I would say just
try it just jump back in and download
the updates pretty hefty update but you
haven't played in a while that new map
is pretty cool characters Eric says I
Donna City in touch season 3 all right
let me make a sound decision before we
get any further for sure I'm gonna see
if I can
although I'm like world's edge it's just
it feels so much bigger
I feel like areas yeah I'm still lost in
those cases like I tend to feel more
comfortable when i alright free
[Music]
all right I turned my sound back up
so my headphones was I can like it was
kind of quiet but hopefully it's a lot
better now that's just me I'm here with
you all right
do you think you heard someone else like
that sometimes in this game like I don't
want to stay somewhere too long or I
hear ya
okay don't eat all sorts of stuff there
we go
Sean Jackson said I liked inside hey
we're here everyone yeah we do like the
live streams
oh shoot wrong scope here we go see I
was like I have one that was last game
loser let me know if you see a shield
I've had bad luck with shields all
morning i pinged a blue one oh shoot
it's still in there for now but he sees
someone so oh right a mirage yeah y'all
about to get bamboozled yeah I gotta
remember that you're talking mirages so
I just remember you here boozled we all
need to take advantage of my new wall
climbing abilities I'm seriously not
taking advantage of his his purse enough
to be honest
ooh I'm so fast so slick with the
movement here
thank you can hear my metal feet just
why Mirage so I can hear my good looks
I found a Spitfire it's been a while so
if you see any attachments for 45
seconds any reasons not close
hot side
here comes all there's three dang I
usually like the are you 4045 but it
feels like more jumpy now like all I
know is being Raj wasn't the business
for me I gotta go back to being life
line Reagan I just like using a zip line
to get squeezed to that fine it was like
the last character I use I try to get
used to him and I didn't enjoy my time
playing with him but I didn't really get
into it he did yeah there was like son
of people there Jonathan it was pretty
brutal
it sucked I was down I was looking I had
to have been tumor in squads because I
saw we knock down one person we knock
down and like Tate knock down one then I
killed one and then there was a revenant
no like oh yeah you were surrounded
there was a guy on your level there was
I'm actually the guy on the ground I
thought he would be the only one that's
why when I was failing with all climb I
was like this is it let's go
all right Eric says I knock one down but
yeah but Pathfinder came over and
destroyed me yeah you're ready to use it
like brutal going back with one help in
the middle of a firefight yeah it me
actually no I don't want it to be me
there
it's Burgess you see that mean of like
your jump master and it's like holding
it like playing hot potato like I don't
want you
[Applause]
who can we do it
that's good no one there people below us
but they're gonna land earlier there
probably during the land on the train
oh right you know what
they're on the train oh they're on it
already
oh he did Lynn oh I thought he's landed
on the dream Eric yeah he is on the
train oh sorry say I thought people are
on there so I abandon ship we can now
pick it up
meanwhile it's pretty quiet over here
fortunately he stopped the train oh
thanks we'll make our way over Haiti
found a purple shield
okay okay brother actually hate being
John master because I'm too indecisive
for that yeah when I play with randoms I
don't care but when I'm playing with my
friends I'm like a media anxiety and
panic the second things I mean while
it's like five million yards away all
right let me pick up y'all's scraps over
here I think maybe I should snake
all right let's go okay yeah trying to
stream snape us
I mean it's fair I'm sure it's hard for
you it's hard for you enough as it is
trying to play without streams name
thing I'm sure it's actually pretty
impressive considering our stream delay
oh so intense it is huh got a digital
threat here
[Music]
the purple she's down but I need
protection
[Music]
I think I mean Aki no I don't see let's
go hide him
I like you crazy well y'all I got one
kill Brian
[Music]
that was pretty funny body fly and his
death box I don't have a scope for this
I need a bigger backpack let me know if
you see one I just picked one up ah
there's a prowler here but I don't have
a select-fire that's how I roll
I'm too indecisive relives I'm like
let's do you like me too me too I need a
moment
just breathe to breathe hmm
use my totem I need an optimal time so
the whole squad but I just do need to
use my abilities for however using his
uh climbing his extended climbing
ability that came in the clutch right
there okay they're just like camping on
the roof waiting for us to come up the
only two leaves go up and I just went
right up the side of the building legs
you got him what what there's just all
these random things on the side of the
wall all right so I'm gonna catch up to
you guys now it's like when you're
already on the ring like barely gonna
yeah now we're just kind of sitting
around waiting Blue Shield's mmm as I
can wish the flatline today or this
match at least I had one and then I
found a Spitfire like I just like the
Spitfire so that
I can never have to reload yeah I need a
man for a year across the fire oh there
[Music]
is a gold shield I might be toast
there's a revenant he's probably gonna
help up that opportunity
[Music]
oh yeah
right now y'all another one there I took
one out
oh I only have 20 and seven bullets
laser gun that's not good news yeah let
me know if you see any heavy ammo I'm oh
I just picked them up because I really
needed it no biggie
whoo all right I'm out we can't stay in
one spot too long there's too many
stream snipers over here oh but the ring
is gonna hit us in this dress okay
they're fighting someone else
yeah
[Applause]
easily I said I'm looking round
oh no that's protection is out
definitely
sorry I'm looking for watch it back to
the ring it's got a bleed out there we
go got him yeah get a gold shield though
I'm freaking out y'all okay two squads
left wait what it's aliens gods up all
right I guess we should make moves
towards something Oh knocking down rush
rush rush over there
okay Hummer oh boy yeah do you think
it's just one guy
golde Sheila okay you know what there's
no time for this
the only time for me to continue to fail
at this job
hold on my hands are sweaty I got a
white okay it was just a bangle or a big
either that or you guys pick up the
other two but I just wiped out that
bangle boy
thanks Jay I saw snipe in action over
there yeah we were well-rounded to do
group that shoot at that time well
rounded goop goop brand yeah I know I
was running out of ammo and I was like I
really am scared of this fight yo look
at her look at our damage pretty good
the best damage I got the most kills and
I'm right there tucked nicely in the
middle just like good team go team six
five five man that was good one we got
one and we have two minutes left so we
probably have time for one more game
yeah Thank You chat we won even with the
stream snipers well they were there Hugh
me communities are for Friday's but
that's what happens that was great I
feel good too let's just end the stream
there look yeah see you guys it's like
we got one more get that bag back
back-to-back dubs I found a golden
devotion in someone's death box that
kind of help came through clutch very
clutch Maria
I love the Brian in the chat life line
with two
doing your job yeah oh man if I didn't
revive Eric we would have been toast
oh no we ranked up this is bad I don't
want to be in a higher rank I'm gonna
like run I thought that said crap the
monitors in a bar who is Richie's
looking at Liam it's your boy that's me
and inducing Jenna's Eric tape that's me
everywhere I think I locked down
Richie's on like every social media and
game platform yeah my heart is still
going check it out I can check the heart
rate right now let's see
yeah it's a little higher than normal my
heart rate was up after a win that's how
it goes when this dream sniper tries to
kill you but guys on your stream instead
good thing it happens I mean it's fine
if you really want to get down and play
that's cool it's hard to stream tonight
but I know I was like I'm actually
impressed you guys to get into our game
we have like a 30-second dream though
check out this
okaythat's heels like always here with
me here's someone rummaging for guns
[Laughter]
well now that the turbochargers oh god
you scared the [ __ ] out of me stranger
danger
yeah 99 yeah that's the Richie
nighty-night
hey all right
here's someone I think it might have
been you now if I just had a purple
lightning that would be great run pistol
only you want oh I will if I get some
good attachments I'm in there well Eric
scare the [ __ ] I mean ow - y'all need a
quick plane and I can use the other one
there's enough to go around
oh man and I found a flat line and you
guys want you to do double bezel only
you know what we're doing double pistols
for the last game extended leymah okay
I'll be on me with that because then
I'll be pretty much unstoppable wait I
don't need heavy ammo there you go yes
are you 45 over 90
yes really uh I don't know I mean I'm
like the only one who feels that way but
I feel that way I've had like good luck
with are you 45 I just never considered
it a main because I'm too scared
and the r99 is it's good good to me
I know Erasmus voice lines are so
hilarious they are even when you try to
thank him he's like I'm not thanking
yeah shut up
skin bag when you revive him he's like
you've saved me I'll spare you and I'm
like yeah you're Evan and I see the
trailers made I'm creepy I'm just trying
to peacefully loo let me know if you
find any old helmet I just need a helmet
I can ping that to everybody
normally the floor is littered with
helmets great we have like three blue
ones right next to each other layer yeah
of course the matches where we don't
need it
circles wait did you get a helmet yet I
guess it's in this building
Louis Spitfire oh yeah see you havoc and
an R 301 damn switching out all my guns
I don't know that's a bad sign this guy
died and I'm picking up I heard that the
person who voices revenant is from over
the person who voices Brian hurt ok I'm
on the ground floor I need to get closer
if I'm going to engage because I'm
rocking I'm on the ground for you guys
whatever they can't nerf me yard at
first I'm going as bait on the ground
floor
I have my death totem back there now
they're surrounding us
oh that's your y'all I had the wrong
almost not bad
two out of three almost
first I gotta saw her bad he did yeah
both freaking out as he was like on the
growling oh dang alright not a bad match
yeah no it's just the last one in
perfect timing
my attempts at a double pistol loadout
clearly that's what sank us I'm just
kidding obviously when I stopped
reviving Eric and I pulled out my pistol
I thought I had the RV but I had the
wingman and I was like difference but
yeah all good look how salty are we
lightly salted like those Lay's exactly
what do you think Chad oh you called it
it's officially done for today you guys
thank you so much for tuning in watching
more revenant gameplay and more season
four of apex legends tomorrow we've got
the battle for the grid developers
coming back to play and show off some
brand new features lobbies have come to
battle for the grid new characters patch
update the whole shebang and shady cable
will be here to show it off and play
matches against you guys to Mario's to
tune in at 11 a.m. Pacific time tomorrow
and every other week days so gonna hang
out with this good come on back come on
it's only Wednesday we're here till
Friday we'll see you guys later bye
you
you